ce visage royal c'est celui de madame
elisabeth soeur du roi louis saez et
belles soeurs de marie antoinette
une exposition inédite du conseil
général des yvelines propose de se
plonger dans l'univers de cette
princesse à travers 130 oeuvres ont à
peu près la moitié sont des prés du
château de versailles qui est partenaire
de l'exposition
beaucoup d'oeuvres sont inédites elles
ont appartenu aux dames de madame
elisabeth ce sont des cadeaux que la
princesse a fait à ses amis et ses
cadeaux étaient conservés dans les par
les descendants donc dans ces familles
et n'ont jamais été présentés pour la
plupart les pièces les plus étonnantes
les bijoux que la princesse
confectionnés à partir de ses propres
cheveux pour les offrir en gage d'amitié
dans la demeure du domaine de madame
elisabeth on découvre l'ambiance de
l'époque le mobilier et la décoration si
emblématiques comme dans ce salon turcs
ou une chaise en toile de jouy lé verte
appelée voyeuse permettait à la
princesse de s'appuyer pour jouer
l'expérience des visiteurs est aussi
sensorielle des extraits de harpe et
aussi des bornes de senteurs rose fleur
d'oranger ou chocolat chaud et des
échantillons de matériaux est issu a
touché des modèles de karak aux jupes et
autres tenues à la mode sont présentés
dont l'unique robe en chemise préservés
en france
après ça la visite se poursuit à
l'extérieur avec une déambulation dans
le jardin thématique reconstituer voit
bien cette barrière de d'agrumes qui
ferme le jardin un petit peu champêtre
et anglophile où on va dire anglais un
petit peu libre et le jardin les humeurs
des humeurs de princesse soigner à
l'époque grâce à des plantes aromatiques
en pot quand le roi venait visiter les
jardins il fallait que tout soit parfait
donc le plus simple était d'enlever une
plante et l'art d'être parent pauvre ça
faisait quatre ou à éviter de puiser
dans les massifs
l'exposition se termine dans l'orangerie
sur le destin tragique de la petite
fille du roi louis 15 elle est
emprisonnée et meurt en martyr
guillotinée en 1794